dieser zug bringt den tod
russland lässt weitere truppen und
waffen in die ukraine verlegen
dieser aus ihr kurz kommende xxl zu
bringt schwere waffen an die front im
donbass
insgesamt 27 selbstfahrende lafetten des
typs 2 s5 militär trucks und munition
die nachrichtenagentur reuters
verbreitet die bilder des
waffentransport
die region luhansk liegt im osten der
ukraine und bildet zusammen mit der
region donezk den don was
dort konzentriert das russische militär
seit wochen seine offensive mit
dem xxl waffen zug ist damit zu rechnen
dass russland eine gewaltige offensive
starten wird wo genau der zug seine
tödliche ladung hinbringt unklar